next let's meet dr ray kanan she's going
to be speaking on bioinformatics in the
beauty industry
dr karen kanan has an phd in
computational biology from the weisman
institute of science in israel she was
the royal society dorothy hodgins fellow
at cambridge university with over 20
years of experience in computational
cancer genomics
now inspired by the paradigm shift in
the one size fits all to precision
medicine
rhea envisioned
similar changes in wellness and beauty
so she co-founded life gnome an
award-winning company that leverages
biological physiological and behavioral
data to personalize wellness
interventions in the prevention in the
preventive health nutrition and personal
care beauty industries
ray is both a researcher
academician as well as entrepreneur reya
we can't wait to hear how this type of
data the technologies and all that are
being used to bring about new treatments
but we also hope to hear in other
domains as well as beauty welcome thank
you very much do you hear me okay
perfect yes we can hear you fine and
your presentation can be seen well thank
you perfect
um so many thanks for the introduction
and thanks to the organizers for
inviting me
so this is going to be a very subjective
overview
on the increasingly important role
that bioinformatics plays in the beauty
industry
my name is raya hanin and i'm a
scientific co-founder of life nom a
genomics ai wellness company
so some of you may be asking
what bioinformatics has to do with
beauty
actually a lot
so when i started preparing for this
talk i quickly realized that
applications of bioinformatics in the
beauty industry have grown tremendously
in the last couple of years
so i will highlight the most
prominent trends
and that have been driven by
bioinformatics i will give some examples
of big companies and startups in this
area
and also we'll talk a little bit about
the challenges that
bioinformatics faces in the beauty
industry
uh so to put things into perspective
the beauty industry is actually huge
it is strong it's getting only stronger
and it's predicted to exceed
780 billion dollars in about five years
so what is beauty industry it actually
covers a wide variety of personal care
products skin care hair care cosmetics
fragrances beauty tech
services various related functions so
these figures do not include dermatology
but our conversation is relevant to
dermatology as well
okay
so let's talk about skin
uh as a computational biologist
i view skin our largest organ as a
complex system of interacting biological
components and the exposure
so the exposure is everything our skin
interacts with that's water environment
temperature pollutants toxins and also
all the products that we put on our skin
from basic soap to very sophisticated
skin care
and obviously skin is a reflection of
all the physiological processes
that are going on inside our bodies so
skin is also our
immune organ as well
so uh out of 20 000 proteins human
proteins
70
are actually expressed in skin and about
500 proteins have elevated expression
and skin compared to other tissues
and these proteins are regulatory and
signaling their receptors and enzymes so
understanding their roles in skin
homeostasis and skin aging is extremely
important
furthermore there are various non-coding
rnas from small
rnas like micrornas to long non-coding
rnas that contribute to skin aging and
skin disorders and actually we still
don't know much about their functions
then of course there is our second
scheme
then of course i don't know there is
message to me or to general god okay
um
so then of course there is our second
skin the microbiome so these are all the
millions of microbes that live on our
skin
and they too change with aging with
environments and various phenotypes for
example dry skin as i will show a couple
of examples
acne and so on
so for a while studies on the skin
microbiome have led behind research on
gut microbiome but actually the beauty
industry and the whole research on skin
is quickly catching up
so obviously um
you know all these considerations are as
important
for hair
as they are for skin
and
as you can imagine lots of research is
going into understanding hair health and
hair brain
and hair baldness
so what if we could predict and reverse
for example hair loss
but i will mainly talk about skin
here
um okay so
in other words there is a complex um
interplay between
human proteins human rnas and
microbiomes
and also um different fungi and viruses
that live on our skin at the same time
microbiomes produce and release
different metabolites and peptides
and all this complex network of
interactions protect the skin from the
environment and interacts with the
exposom and
skin care ingredient
i call it systems biology of beauty
so you see here
the
unilever logo
and this figure was actually taken from
a special skin microbiome issue from
nature
journal sponsored by
ioneliva in fact all major personal care
companies from unilever procter gamble
l'oreal heavily invest in
bioinformatics and genomics sciences
they all actively work
on generating proprietary genomics data
sets
sophisticated data analysis methods
and they develop computational models
and pipelines
but this has not always been the case
a few years back that's another um
article from the
from nature journal called molecular
beauty
um they cite
uh a prominent dermatologist from a
lydian hospital in boston who says that
until actually a couple of decades ago
the beauty industry was almost allergic
to science
the common perception was that consumers
were scared off and uninterested in
sites so companies didn't want
this word to be associated with their
products but that aversion started to
melt
with the advent of genomics which not
only transformed research but also
captured the public imagination
and uh in this
paper they cite
scientists from the brand ole at
consumer goods company procter gamble
who says that
over the years we've converged on an
understanding that we should be doing
really deep biology on the skin aging
process and on products that can be used
to improve skin health it's just like
any other biological endpoint that a
pharmaceutical company would go after
so just like pharma just like in pharma
bioinformatics and machine learning i
expected to make the search for new
ingredients new formulas quicker cheaper
and more effective
so perhaps initially the beauty industry
was nearly following what pharma was
doing
but just because of the nature of its
business
and willingness of consumers to actually
contribute their data
so-called citizen science the beauty
industry with the help of bioinformatics
and machine learning can actually move
faster make more discoveries in
particular in
anti-aging and longevity science i will
give an example of such a company
uh in a few minutes
so i will now
highlight a couple of major trends in
the beauty industry that have been
driven by bioinformatics
so firstly an unstoppable trend is
synthetic beauty sustainability and
ingredient transparency
so biotechnologies are increasingly
impacting their production of beauty
ingredients from algae
to
marine based components
companies produce some ingredients in
the lab and these ingredients
can be some commonly used uh collagen
spoiling and palm oil
to some rare ingredients such as for
example
unique scents of roses without actually
relying on expensive rose petals that's
ginkgo bio
perhaps the most fascinating example of
a new generation of beauty company is
archaea
uh which recently received funding of 78
million dollars from chanel javadon and
vcs and the goal of the company is to
create sustainable
previously inaccessible ingredients
for beauty industry through what they
call expressive biology
so this is a screenshot from their
website
where they call biology the most
sophisticated technology on the planet
it has unparalleled precision and scale
that modern means have never been able
to replicate
at archaea they combine technology from
the past and present
region biology
with dna sequencing bioinformatics
fermentation
and storytelling to create new products
experiences
for beauty
another huge trend
is beauty further integrating with the
whole wellness economy
uh pandemic obviously accelerated this
trend the whole trend of self-care
focusing on one's health wellness with
an added spotlight on immunity
and there is an overlap here with
nutrigenomics personalized nutrition and
also special emphasis on sleep and
mental health
additionally there is increasing
interest and research on longevity
so people are planning to live longer
and they want to look
younger
and in this respect
uh skin aging is obviously the most
recognizable and often the most kind of
psychologically difficult aspect of
injury
at the same time skin aging is
potentially also one of the most
amenable for
intervention
prevention and rejuvenation
so skin actually can be regarded as an
ideal model for studying tissue aging
and i'm going to talk about a specific
example here a company called one skin
which i find absolutely fascinating so
what they did initially
they um analyzed publicly available data
actually that's methylation data and
here's all the data sets that they've
analyzed
and they developed
a
highly accurate skin specific
skin specific
a biological clock for skin
so
they showed you know they validated it
they showed
uh on an independent cohort its accuracy
what they did next
was
they used this
method
as a screening platform for different
compounds
they screened hundreds of peptides and
they found one they call it peptide 14
that effectively decreased chronological
aging
uh uvb
radiation by modulating longevity and
senescence pathways
so basically they showed that this
specific peptide promoted skin health
reduced senescent cell markers as well
as the biological age of samples
they showed next that this specific
peptide actually outperformed the
current golden standard in the
anti-aging skin care the retinal
treatment
so and then this scientists four female
phds from brazil originally
they um raised funds and they started
a company called one scheme and you can
actually now buy
uh their products
uh
which they call skin supplements
uh the product is unisex and it's for
skin and body and uh i highly recommend
it it's very good
um okay so the next trend um in beauty
is and in medicine as well
is personalization obviously it's not a
new concept
but it's getting more sophisticated
it started with quizzes
it's moved to
selfies
various skin and hair scanning devices
and
now it is uh powered by biology so
biology is the ultimate frontier of
personalization
and genetics and microbiome are driving
this trend
so here i would like to highlight two
studies
the first one is relatively old um
2009
uh and
it looked at
many hundreds of tweens
and uh identified that about 60 of skin
age is actually determined by our
genetics
about 40
is determined by the environment
another study
uh followed
a thousand people for over 10 years
and found that actually some people age
much faster than the others and this is
visible in their physical
characteristics as well as in their skin
features
so the authors of this study
built an ai predictor using genetics and
i have other biomarkers
and they quantified aging in younger
people thus allowing for intervention
and prevention
so
there are
numerous genome-wide association studies
on genetics of skin
uh skin health skin aging
um there are snips
identified to be connected to different
um
skin features such as early wrinkles or
photo aging
so this information can be used to
predict
not immediately observable skin age
and several companies
including lifenom the company that i
co-founded offer beauty-focused dna
testing kits informing consumers on
their genomic skin traits
curate ingredients and products and
develop personalized
products and services
so
dna tests are becoming a commodity right
i'm talking about genotyping tests
and
in the us you can buy them in your local
cvs store
probably over 30 million people have
taken um at home ancestry tests and as
you all know the if sheep contains about
600 000 snips
with imputation that's a few million so
it's a lot of information that can be
used
um
by beauty companies to look into skin
health and skin
aging so lots of
very interesting discoveries can be made
here
uh so it's life known
we are developing a
beauty personalized platform that uses
genomics ai
um
well we use machine learning you
probably heard the joke that if it's
written in python it's probably machine
learning if it's written in powerpoint
it's ai
so actually when you work with beauty
companies everything is a i
um
so jokes aside we built a huge
knowledge base
that integrates data from thousands of
studies including
gene expression studies
and what our platform does it utilizes
consumer dna with the survey
and
informs consumers about their potential
risks and offers uh ingredient
recommendation product recommendation we
also collect feedback and obviously
build new insights we identify new
genetic based
features for example sensitivities to
specific ingredients such as retinol
i will now switch gears and talk about
microbiome
so this is probably the biggest trend in
beauty
uh the quartus trend so cosmetic
formulators are developing their own
microbiome franchises they design
health enhancing skin care products that
contain bacteria
bacteria extracts or ingredients that
are meant to enhance skin microbe
activity
and then instagram and beauty magazines
are educating their readers water
prebiotics post biotics and probiotics
and as i mentioned before all major
personal care companies
have been working in this area and also
a number of very innovative startups
and indie brands have launched uh
products that use microbiome
so
this is from a company from a dutch
company dsm
and they developed an ingredient that
they called epi volume beauty
this specific ingredient
relieving skin dryness
and they showcase a clinical study
where
participants use this ingredient and
kind of the
the bad bacteria
was decreasing with using a usage of
this ingredient while the good bacteria
was
increasing
interestingly uh tech companies are also
partnering with beauty companies and
attempting to solve similar problems
this is an example of ibm partnering
with unilever
and again an article from nature journal
and they also study a similar problem
they study um
an issue of skin hydration here they use
uh explainable ai
they identify a signature of microbes
uh that
that is associated with skin trainers
so that's i think is very interesting uh
partnerships between tech companies and
views
uh and as i mentioned there is a number
of very innovative startups
in this field
uh s biomedic symbiom dermala each of
these companies claims to harness the
power of microbiome and address
skin conditions like acne rosacea
and different features related to skin
aging
other companies like skin trust
sequential skin doctor elsa jungman or
for skin microbiome tests
it's a big business
and
at the same time it's data collection
it's citizen signs and it enables future
discoveries so needless to say that
behind all this brand messaging and
marketing all this work is enabled by
bioinformatics and in fact some of these
companies have bioinformaticians among
their founders
so that's another example of a company
jivo dan
and in addition to doing taxonomic
analysis
excuse me
they actually uh explore which jobs the
microbiota can do so they do functional
microbiome analysis
um
okay so bioinformatics powers microbiome
trends in beauty
so all these companies
require
development improvements and maintenance
of robust bioinformatics pipelines for
efficient and fast processing of
large-scale metagenomics data
so they needed to detect known species
identify new species and so on and
bioinformaticians would appreciate
that it requires infrastructure for
storage for the usage and so on
so and all the tools that bioinformatics
has developed are also required here
from machine learning supervised
unsupervised analysis pathways analysis
and so on
and for those interested in challenges
there are plenty
discovering functions of species new
microbial pathways metabolites and so on
so i see that
the notion here that my time is
almost coming up so i'll skip couple of
things here
and kind of
say that there are lots of pros working
as bioinformatician in the beauty in
industry it's easy to collect data it's
past turnaround
it's still a new area of application
there are many challenging problems to
be solved
and lots of opportunities at the same
time
there are many proprietary data sets
lots of secrecy
fast turnaround you can see your
favorites past two and even if you have
great science you also need to learn
some storytelling branding and marketing
so you need to learn some beauty like
and i'll skip here and
happy to answer your questions and
please connect with me
discuss with me if you have any interest
in bioinformatics in beauty
many thanks for your attention
thank you we that was really interesting
um the personalization it's going to be
interesting to see where that goes in
the next couple years if you want to
pull your powerpoint down i do have a
couple questions for you
um why do you think metagenomics
specifically is so important for the
beauty and wellness research and then
how can it be integrated with other
types of omics
data why is it important oh sorry yes
stop share yeah
um
i mean it's um there are several i mean
in terms of beauty it's easy to measure
somehow
um people are not people actually
willing to share their skin microbiome
they're not as willing to share their
dna but
they are really interested to learn what
microbes live on their skin
in terms of challenges
i think the challenges are the same as
uh yesterday somebody from sweden was
talking about integrating different
layers of multi-omics data challenges
are the same
as in any other area but i kind of
predict that integration in the beauty
industry will happen a bit faster again
because people are willing to learn
more
uh about their skin they want to look
healthy they want to look young so there
is this younger younger i'll take
younger
me too yes
so that's kind of
what i think okay
what's the integration look like
what's the integration looks like the
integration like for other type of omics
some maybe some fields or whatever
uh it can be um
something that you know it's not just
easy to detect using one type of data
uh like for example microbiome and
genetics or metabolomics and
transcriptomics
but by combining two types of data you
can actually identify the sort of the
compound bio compound score if you like
so if you take biomarkers from different
types of or mixed data
a question from the audience i'm sorry a
question from the audience are you using
ancestry data in the research
for instance from the gsa
um ancestry as in you mean in terms of
ethnic differences in aging yes
okay
yeah yeah
okay
um
there are other fields in the beauty
industry where bioinformatics research
is actively conducted do you have any
examples
other areas other than those that are
mentioned
i mean all the skin disorders uh skin
conditions acne rosacea
sensitivity these are all huge um areas
where you know lots of research is going
on yes
okay
have environmental issues such as global
warming pollution contributed to the
growth of the beauty industry and then
if so how does bioinformatics help in
the process
excellent question yes um
so i mentioned i think in the first
trend was the
sustainability concern and this is why
uh bioinformatics and synthetic biology
they're working on developing new
sustainable ingredients
obviously
uh and this is going to grow this is i
think we're just at the kind of
beginning of this development
uh and in terms of pollution and global
warming obviously it does affect uh our
skin
uh that's for sure and
again i just today saw an article how
the anti-pollution skincare is going to
grow in the next couple of years
yeah definitely a huge huge uh area
where do you think the uh
this will be the last question the
future of personalized skin care
solutions where do you think that's
headed
i think it's actually heading where you
know you'll have your little station
kind of at home
and
you know your microbiome and
meta metabolomics of your skin will be
measured at certain regular intervals
will be sent to some center
and then you will receive uh you know
your personalized products for your skin
depending on seasonality depending where
you are in a big city in the countryside
etc so definitely we're heading that
direction so it will be a few more years
before that but
the vector is there yes
well very good well thank you again dr
kanan for your incredible work in this
field
congratulations on the success of your
award-winning company thank you much for
being here today thank you thank you
you're welcome